thanks to mack weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me
look fly president trump caused quite a
stir when he tweeted that the election
should be delayed because
democrats were about to commit mass
voter fraud by encouraging people to
vote by mail
now i've already covered the possibility
of election delays in my video can the
president cancel the election
and i and most people came to the
conclusion that because
the election is enshrined in the
constitution that president trump
probably cannot
delay or cancel the election but
president trump's recent comments about
voting by mail raise a different issue
entirely not canceling the election or
postponing the election
but voter suppression and according to
the president
voting by absentee ballot is safe while
voting by mail
is unsafe apparently unaware that those
are basically the same
thing the trump campaign recently sued
the state of nevada
for its plan to send every registered
voter a ballot
now why are states suddenly interested
in increasing opportunities to vote by
mail
and are there legal and security
differences in how mailed ballots and
absentee ballots are handled and
counted and does the president have the
power to change the way that states run
their elections
well today we're going to learn about
the laws that regulate elections the
prevalence of voter fraud or lack
thereof and the safety of
mail-in votes and absentee ballots
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because we have an election
coming up
and the presence of the kobit 19
pandemic has changed
absolutely everything and i never
thought i'd say this but it appears that
the president
is trying to get people not to vote
in the november election i've said it
before and i'll say it again
democracy simply doesn't work so the
first question we need to ask is who
regulates voting
in general well there's actually a fair
amount of federalism
in voting the u.s constitution elections
clause article 1 section 4
empowers the states to determine the
quote time place and manner
of congressional elections subject to
congress's authority to make or alter
state regulations
dividing the power between the states
and federal government is a cornerstone
of american federalism
state and local governments therefore
have the authority to enact laws
for such elections including rules
concerning public notices voter
registration voter protection
fraud protection vote counting and
determination of election results
however congress may pass federal laws
regulating congressional elections
which then automatically preempt any
contrary state statutes
and congress can also enact its own
regulations if the states didn't address
something
important but remember both congress and
state governments are constrained by the
other protections guaranteed by the
constitution
for example if a state imposes barriers
to voting that violate the 14th
amendment
the laws can be challenged as
unconstitutional during the jim crow era
states enacted laws designed to stop
black voters from voting such as
literacy tests
property ownership requirements and
mandatory payment of fees
known as poll taxes but for the most
part the laws that regulate how a person
votes
such as what time the polls open and
close the deadline for registering or
the assignment of polling places are all
examples of decisions that the elections
clause of the constitution
allows for the states to make so the
vast majority of laws that govern
elections
are handled by the states and neither
the president the executive
or congress has anything to really say
about that particular regulation
but what about election security
congress has never passed significant
legislation mandating security
procedures for paper ballots or
electronic ballots even elections
equipment including the software from
private vendors is mostly unregulated
and in the absence of federal laws
states have developed their own security
protocols many experts have argued that
congress
should probably step in and regulate
security procedures to create uniformity
amongst the states
including federal agencies and actually
in november of 2019
several federal agencies including
homeland security the justice department
and the fbi
released a joint statement naming
election security as quote a top
priority for the united states
government these agencies were chiefly
concerned about
threats from foreign countries and other
bad actors congress did not pass an
election security bill after this
warning and when democrats tried to add
funding for voter security measures to
legislation addressing the covet-19
crisis
specifically targeting the safety of
voting by mail president trump described
it as a scam to stop
republicans from winning objections
stating quote you'd never have a
republican elected in this country again
if the money for mail-in voting was
included in the bill
and there is some truth to the
president's statement even if it is a
crass political truth which is that
research tends to show that when
voter turnout goes up it favors the
democrats and disfavors the republicans
but saying that you actually want lower
voter turnout is a bit like saying the
quiet part out loud
but that takes us to the covid19 crisis
now before the kobit 19 pandemic the
main concern about the security of
voting systems was
the software and hardware used to tally
scan
collate and report votes could be
manipulated or
hacked and truthfully that probably
deserves
its own video because our electronic
voting systems are
woefully inadequate and really need
additional security measures but the
primary concern changed when the kovid
19 pandemic hit
no longer were people so worried about
the electronic voting at
actual formal polling places but instead
people didn't want to leave their homes
and since we don't have a system of
being able to vote electronically from
home
the emphasis changed to voting by male
and absentee ballots
and in a way this seemed like a perfect
solution people could vote from home
uh minimizing the risk of transmitting
or receiving the covet-19 virus
and many politicians on both sides of
the aisle and
many different states were trying to
encourage people to vote by
mail now i have been using the terms
absentee voting and
voting by mail almost interchangeably
but let's talk about the difference
between those two terms practically
speaking
as it regards an individual ballot
there's almost no difference if you vote
by mail or vote by absentee you are
taking your ballot you're filling it out
at home or some other place and you are
mailing it into the place that's going
to register your vote
really the only difference is in terms
of scale an absentee ballot is sort of
an exception to the general rule if
you're unable to
go to a physical polling place or you
live outside of the state temporarily
then you can ask for an absentee ballot
you can fill it out and then send it in
to the polling place as an exception to
the general rule that you would have to
go in in person
voting by mail is effectively the same
thing just a difference of scope instead
of
asking for an absentee ballot as an
exception
everyone can vote by mail regardless of
whether they meet the criteria for an
absentee ballot or not
and states differ in terms of whether
you need to
formally register ahead of time for a
mail-in ballot or whether the state will
just send
every registered voter a mail-in ballot
without having to pre-register
and while voting by mail is certainly
getting a lot of scrutiny now it's
definitely nothing new
some states including washington utah
and colorado have been
voting only by mail for several years
initially mail-in voting was supported
by both republicans and democrats
however
president trump was disturbed by this
development and he started tweeting his
concerns about alleged differences
between absentee ballots and vote by
mail
in the president's mind it appears that
absentee ballots are good
and mail-in ballots are bad and you get
thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebody's living room
signing ballots all over the place no i
think that
mail-in voting is a terrible thing does
that
really happen the short answer is no
because there's little practical
difference between absentee ballots and
mailed ballots president trump's own
lawyers even admit this in a lawsuit
challenging pennsylvania's mail-in
voting rules
the president's campaign says that quote
the terms mail-in and absentee are used
interchangeably to discuss the use of
the united states postal service to
deliver ballots to
and from elections so let's dig in a
little bit deeper into the various
states voting laws
all states allow voters who have a
reason they can't vote on election day
to request a ballot in advance
while a majority of states currently let
all voters ask for a ballot in advance
without needing an excuse for why the
person can't vote in person and some
states adhere to the traditional concept
of an absentee ballot an absentee ballot
technically is an old term that meant
someone was voting by mail because on
election day they would be absent from
the jurisdiction
in which they lived and 16 states still
only permit
certain voters to request an absentee
ballot by mail when they have
an excuse for not being able to vote at
the polls on election day either that
they won't be in the jurisdiction on
that day or that they have an illness or
disability
this is the traditional meaning of
voting absentee in all states
military voters who are mostly covered
by federal law are permitted to vote
absentee
the states have a range of other excuses
that justify voting absentee like
medical emergency confinement to jail or
confinement to medical
facility and many states also give
special help to those who can't vote in
person
for example in arizona election
officials will deliver an absentee
ballot to voters confined due to a
medical emergency
but that's in contrast to what's called
no excuse mailed ballots
delays and problem at polling locations
frequently caused the kind of disturbing
problems
that we see on election day long lines
broken electronic voting machines and
people turned away because
time ran out state legislatures
addressed some of these problems by
expanding the number of days for
early in-person voting and eliminating
restrictions as to who can vote
absentee or by mail this is why 34
states and washington dc have what's
called
no excuse absentee or mail-in voting and
a quick note on terminology since state
laws are not identical you may see
states using different terminology like
advanced ballots mailed ballots
buy mail ballots and vote by mail
ballots although different terms are
used generally they mean the same thing
and although the word mail is used in
almost all of them
this means that the ballots are mailed
to the voter voters can send them back
via the mail
but all states also allow the voters to
drop them off at designated secure
locations
voters who live in these states don't
need to claim that they will be out of
the jurisdiction or that they have any
kind of illness or emergency that makes
it impossible for them to vote in person
and some states like oregon washington
hawaii and colorado
automatically send a ballot to every
registered voter and
some people hate this but now is
probably a good time to talk about some
of the misconceptions
about the security or security problems
of no excuse mail-in ballots the main
claim that
president trump and various republicans
are making is that
no excuse absentee ballots are less
secure than absency ballots that
require an excuse president trump says
that there are very strict protocols for
absentee ballots
but that these strict security protocols
aren't used for
mailed ballots and this is strictly
speaking
not factual the states don't have two
separate systems for voters who will be
absent from their voting district and
those who prefer to
vote by mail and really each state has
its own security protocols for mailed
ballots and
here's a rundown of the most important
security features one is that
a ballot cannot be mailed to a person
unless they are an eligible and
registered voter
this means that a person must fill out
registration forms and have their
address confirmed
ballots can't be forwarded to a new
address which means that a person must
also have a current address to receive a
ballot in the mail
and generally ballots arriving before
election day are stored in a secure room
some states use security cameras to
monitor the rooms
some received ballots also are stored
using special locks such as locks that
require
bipartisan teams to open and ballots
often have a barcode and this means that
a voter can only be issued one ballot
in states with barcoding it's incredibly
difficult if not effectively impossible
to
simply fill out a new ballot for someone
who has already mailed in a ballot and
had their barcode registered and often
states that
mail every voter a ballot use
multi-layer security envelopes and
signature matching and signature
verification is one of the major
security checks that states use to track
ballots
every ballot is tracked in an election
management system that
tries to prevent double voting and often
every signature that is returned on
every ballot is
then checked against the signature on
file with the voters registration
local officials then determine if the
ballot was returned by an eligible voter
additionally the u.s postal service
recently sent a vote-by-mail kit to over
11
000 local election officials these kits
encourage them to adopt best practices
including the post office's intelligent
mail
barcode which lets mail ballots be fully
documented as they move
to and from voters and can make it
easier to identify
legal votes but obviously no system is
perfect and these measures haven't
stopped the president from predicting
mass voter fraud but let's talk about
voter fraud and how that differs from
voter suppression
voter fraud is the illegal behavior of
individual voters whether you
are fraudulently creating duplicate
votes or you
are fraudulently voting on behalf of
someone who you're not supposed to be
voting for
voter suppression is any effort by the
government or other individuals to
prevent or discourage eligible voters
from registering to vote or
voting itself unfortunately there's a
long history of voter suppression
tactics in this country they can be
very simple and violent measures to
prevent people from voting like
the murders of james chaney andrew
goodman and michael schwerner
who were killed for registering black
voters in mississippi in 1964.
other suppression tactics include
requiring forms of identification that
people have difficulty obtaining or
limiting the hours for early voting so
that people have to balance family and
work obligations
with the need to show up on election day
this is one reason why often people
argue that election day
should be a national holiday so that
more people have the opportunity to vote
and
don't need to make a choice between
going to their job
and voting in a national election and
other voter suppression
tactics can include trying to
disenfranchise people for example making
it a rule that all
felons are unable to vote that is not a
constitutional requirement that if you
are convicted of a felony you
automatically lose the right to vote
suppression tactics can also
include using software that purges
people from the roster of eligible
voters and
sometimes all of these tactics come
together for example florida
purged thousands of alleged felons from
voter rolls in 2000. this was before the
recent florida constitutional amendment
that allowed felons to vote which is
highly controversial and
is up in the courts as we speak but in
that particular case later investigators
discovered that the system purged many
people without felony convictions simply
because they had
the same birth date as a felon or the
first four letters of their name seemed
to match the felons and in georgia in
2018
brian kemp who was then georgia's
secretary of state purged the voter
rolls by eliminating 850 000 voters who
hadn't voted in a while this was called
the use it or
lose it approach and kemp was then
elected governor
that year i'm brian kemp this is jake
young man interested in one of my
daughters yes sir
but apart from voter suppression which
is its own thing and deserves its own
video
there is voter fraud which is ostensibly
what a lot of
people in the trump administration are
worried about so what is voter fraud and
how common is it well there are several
different categories of potential voter
fraud and
let's start with something called double
voting double voting is when a person
votes twice obviously one person can
only vote once in any particular
election
now to prove double voting you just need
proof that someone voted more than once
and most states require voting
documentation to be saved such as
signed poll books double voting is
actually extremely rare the reason for
this is just that it isn't worth it for
a criminal conviction to add one
incremental vote to a candidate's total
when
any particular candidate is going to
have thousands and thousands of votes
each act of voter fraud in connection
with a federal election risks five years
in prison and a ten thousand dollar fine
in addition to any state penalties
for double voting to throw an election
you would need thousands of people in a
jurisdiction willing to take that risk
or you'd need one person to vote
many many times which increases the
chance of getting caught often what
appears to be a double vote is actually
just confusion about the person's
identity in
2004 for example two kathleen sullivans
living in new jersey were confused for
each other that's
a mistake but not voter fraud then you
have the classic kind of
voter fraud involving dead voters the
media frequently runs stories about
dead people voting only to find out
after further investigation that this is
based on
clerical errors more often than the
clerical errors though is that
people simply cast an absentee ballot
and then in the interim before the
election is over they
pass away and while there are certainly
stories of people
filling the ballot boxes with uh the
names of the deceased
at the turn of the 20th century and
things like the chicago
political machine of 100 years ago in
the modern era this kind of voter fraud
is extraordinarily rare
another common claim is that people will
register with fraudulent addresses like
vacant lots or storage units in order
to get more votes this obviously runs
into the same problems with trying to
use the same
name to be able to vote more than once
but not many fake address claims have
been substantiated over the years and
some states maintain a list of
properties and lots that are allegedly
vacant
only to find out later that they
actually now hold houses this actually
happened in missouri in the year 2000
officials also mistakenly challenged
people like barbara taylor
a washington voter who listed her
address as a storage facility turns out
that
taylor managed the storage company and
lived in an apartment on site
and had lived there for 12 years and her
address was in fact legitimate and then
there's the possibility of felony barred
voters and this one's controversial
because
in many states people who are convicted
of felonies
are allowed to vote ironically it's
actually far more likely that a state
will
purge eligible voters from the voting
rolls when they're trying to purge
felons
than it is for people who are convicted
of felonies
from accidentally voting or even
intentionally voting despite the felony
conviction and then finally there is the
possibility of voting by
non-citizens president trump and his
advisors claim that non-citizen
immigrants
voted on mass there's been no evidence
of illegal immigrants really voting at
all let alone
in large numbers this could be because
the penalty for illegally voting is
deportation
while the payoff is minuscule again one
marginal vote in a general election and
of the few documented cases where an
ineligible immigrant voted
most involve innocent mistakes sometimes
people who are going through the
naturalization process are given voter
registration forms which they
turn in before they have actually become
naturalized citizens
and it's worth considering how difficult
this kind of fraud would be to pull off
at scale
in hawaii in 2000 there were allegations
that
533 non-citizens registered to vote but
an investigation revealed that 144 of
those registered voters
actually became citizens and then were
eligible to vote
at least 61 asked the state to cancel
their registrations when they realized
that they were ineligible
two others were stopped at the polls by
poll workers and never voted and there
were no reports substantiating that any
ineligible immigrant actually voted
in that election so it's worth asking
how widespread
is election fraud well the heritage
foundation which is known as a fairly
conservative
think tank maintains a database of
documented instances of voter fraud
they found that over the past 20 years
about 250 million votes have been cast
by mail and ballot nationally
and during that time there have been
just over 1200 cases of fraud of
all forms resulting in 1100 criminal
convictions
of these cases 204 involve the
fraudulent use of absentee ballots
143 resulted in criminal convictions
that amounts to about
point zero zero zero six percent of all
votes casts so when you break that down
that works out to an average of maybe
seven or eight cases of fraud involving
mailed or absentee ballots per year
nationally
and remember oregon has been mailing
ballots to all registered voters
for 20 years so far 50 million ballots
have been cast in oregon alone
with just two verified fraud cases
resulting in
conviction that's point zero zero zero
zero four percent but that's not to say
that we shouldn't be concerned about the
security of our vote
obviously the strength of our democracy
relies on
our votes being authentic and secure but
we should also probably consider what
kinds of fraud cases have been
discovered recently
as it regards mail-in ballots the answer
is that there's been almost
no fraud considering the millions of
ballots that have been cast
of course you don't have to take my word
for it you can actually take the word
of the trump campaign itself because the
trump campaign is actually filing suit
in a number of different states to try
and prevent changes to the way that
elections are run to make it easier
for people to vote and in particular the
trump campaign is actually suing
in pennsylvania to stop the legislature
from
allowing people to vote via drop off
mailboxes
in places other than designated voting
stations
the trump campaign alleged that there
was widespread voter fraud in
pennsylvania and therefore the
changes could not take place after a
lengthy discovery battle where the
defendants
demanded that the trump campaign
actually provide evidence of the fraud
that they claim was taking place
the judge ordered the trump campaign to
provide the evidence of widespread voter
fraud that the trump campaign claimed
existed and when push came to shove
the trump campaign provided basically a
half-dozen
news articles that sort of hinted at
things going on which did not actually
talk about widespread mail-in voter
fraud
so the trump campaign's best evidence
basically
showed nothing of the kind and notice i
said the trump campaign
rather than the president himself
because it's the company that runs the
president's reelection campaign
that is responsible for these lawsuits
which is incredibly problematic because
the campaign can use all the funds at
its disposal which
includes the funds that people have
donated for the president's re-election
those kinds of campaign contributions
are being used to
further what a lot of people are calling
voter suppression tactics to roll back
amendments to voting laws which would
allow for
increased franchisement of people in
states like pennsylvania and nevada
and believe it or not the biggest
verified election fraud scandal in
recent history was actually committed in
north carolina
by republican operative leslie mcrae
dallas who in
2019 was charged with three felony
counts of obstruction of justice
two counts of conspiring to commit
obstruction of justice two counts of
possession of absentee ballots perjury
and solicitation to commit
perjury operatives working for dallas
illegally collected and sometimes filled
in absentee ballots on behalf of
republican mark harris's campaign
harris won by less than a thousand votes
and
as a result of the fraud the state
ordered a new
election now regardless of whether there
is extensive documentation of
actual voter fraud or not that hasn't
stopped the president from saying that
he wants to do something to
change the election so the question is
can the president change the entire
elective system
through executive order and the answer
is that the president does not have the
constitutional authority to make
unilateral changes to the election
system
these issues are largely enshrined in
federal statutes
and state law which an executive order
can't really touch
but the president can undermine voting
and confidence in the outcome of the
election and that may be what the
president
is doing recently new postmaster general
lewis de joy
a trump donor just instituted changes in
the way that the u.s postal service
works
reducing overtime for postal workers
even if that means that mail that's
ready to be delivered
sits at the local post office for
additional days president trump argues
that this is all about building more
efficient postal service
but the timing of these changes
coincides with the president's outbursts
and tirades against mail-in voting house
representative carolyn maloney recently
sent a letter about the reported
operating changes to dejoy complaining
that the quote increases in male
delivery timing
would impair the ability of ballots to
be received and counted in a timely
manner to many people the sudden changes
to the u.s postal service
look like a voter suppression tactic a
majority of states reject ballots that
they aren't delivered by election day
even if they are postmarked in advance
so a slowdown in the mail could be
disastrous for mail-in ballots that are
sent far ahead of time that just simply
don't arrive
by election day and the president has
repeatedly stated that the election must
be decided on the same day that voting
takes place even though
there is no federal or state law that
requires
the actual outcome to be decided on the
same day
in reality the outcome of the
presidential election is not official
until the completion of the canvas of
votes and certification of the results
the canvas means aggregating
and confirming every valid ballot cast
and counted which includes absentee
early voting election day
provisional challenged uniformed and
overseas citizens this doesn't happen
in one night election day is november
2nd states have until december 8
2020 to resolve election disputes and
this means recounts and lawsuits must be
completed by them and
states have a minimum of 35 days to
certify who won the most votes in that
state the person with the most votes
wins
each state's electors with a few
exceptions and the electoral college
meets on december 14th
2020 and cast their ballots the ballots
are of course immediately transmitted to
various people and december 23rd is the
deadline for receipt of all elector's
ballots
from all of the states however there's
no penalty for
missing that particular deadline on
january 6 2021 congress is going to meet
to count the votes and inauguration day
is going to be january 20th
2021. but as promised the trump campaign
is actually making good on the
president's threats to try and stop
mail-in voting
and the trump campaign has actually sued
the state of nevada over the state's new
law expanding mail-in voting for the
2020 general election
according to the lawsuit making all
voters a ballot makes voter fraud quote
inevitable the lawsuit also claims that
mailing all voters ballots
disenfranchises
rural voters violating the equal
protection clause the lawsuit takes
issue with a section of the law
requiring county clerics to quote
establish procedures for the processing
and counting of ballots
the trump campaign's problem with this
is that it's up to each county clerk to
establish the best procedures for
accounting
rather than a uniform system statewide
and you may agree or disagree with the
various different
counties systems that they put in place
and wish that there was a
standardized system throughout the state
but the president's campaign doesn't
have a role in making nevada law and
remember the constitution gives the
states the right to administer
their own elections and it probably
shouldn't surprise you
that making an equal protection claim on
behalf of rural voters doesn't make
any sense at all they're not a protected
class and
i don't see how an equal protection
claim works in this particular context
now personally i think as many people of
all stripes whether democrat or
republican
should vote voting is a public good and
both federal and state governments
should
take more steps to facilitate voting
especially in these coveted times
and mail-in voting seems like a pretty
easy step to make that happen
because we're all staying home more
often not just because of kovid but
because it's so ridiculously hot out and
i've heard stories of people attending
zoom calls with formal business attire
on top and
swimming trunks on the bottom i of
course would never do that but if i did
do that i'd wear mac weldon's awesome
swimming trunks
i'm also not going to rip the suit off
when i finish this video and jump in the
pool wearing mac weldon's designer swim
trunks that look great
in and out of the water but here's a
picture of the last time i wore
those trunks that's definitely me and
not a stock photo of a model i really
needed a tan there
weldon is a men's essential clothing
company that focuses on smart design and
premium fabrics
if i'm not in court or on a zoom call
with the judge i'm often wearing mac
weldon and i've tried their polos their
t-shirts and their shorts
and of course they're world famous boxer
briefs and if you're watching this
channel you're an adult and you probably
deserve to have
really nice boxer briefs and i can tell
you they make a world of difference
i've ordered mac weldon with my own
money multiple times and
it's really easy because i've had
multiple sizes shipped to
try on and then i just returned the ones
that didn't fit and
kept the ones that fit perfectly and if
you would like to try mac welding and
you'd like 20
off your first order just go to
macweldon.com legaleagle or use the
promo code legaleagle at checkout or you
can click
on the link in the description and with
mac weldon's loyalty program you can get
20
off free shipping and access to new
products first it's automatic when you
sign up and order at macweldon.com
legaleagle or you can click on the link
in the description and with mac weldon's
loyalty program you can get 20
off with free strip free stripping no
there will not be any free stripping
with mac weldon's loyalty program though
you can get 20 off with free shipping
and access to new products
it's automatic when you sign up and
order at mountwheldon.com
or use the promo code legaleagle at
checkout for 20 off your first order
and of course clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and if you
want to try out their famous boxer
briefs you can decide for any reason
that you're not satisfied and you can
just keep them and still get a free
refund because
who wants to return used underwear so do
you agree with my analysis do you think
that voter fraud is a real
issue or is it really just the tail
wagging the dog leave your objections in
the comments
and check out my other real law reviews
over here where i talk about all of the
crazy things coming out of the trump
administration and all the legal issues
that we've never had to deal with so
just click
on this playlist and i'll see you in
court